WHINING ABOUT THE CULT OF TRUMP
AFTER EIGHT YEARS OVER SWOONING
OVER THE REAL MESSIAH, OBAMA.
BUT WE BEGIN WITH BROAD SIDES
FROM TEAM TRUMP ON THE CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
STARTING WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP,
SHOT AT THE FBI BRASS AND CHIEF,
THE CHIEF HE FIRED, OF COURSE
JIM COMEY.
ON FOX AND FRIENDS THIS MORNING,
THE PRESIDENT TOOK A SWIPE AT
WHAT HE CALLED THE SCUM AT THE
TOP OF THE BUREAU UNDER OBAMA.
>> THE FBI LOOKS BAD, VERY BAD.
>> NO, IT'S COMEY.
INTERPRET TALKING ABOUT COMEY,
NOT MY FBI.
THE PEOPLE IN THE FBI ARE
INCREDIBLE.
I WOULD BET IF YOU TOOK A POLL
IN THE FBI, I WOULD WIN THAT
POLL BY MORE THAN ANYBODY THAT'S
EVER WON A POLL.
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY WERE PLOTTING AGAINST MY
ELECTION.
PRESIDENTIAL ATTORNEY RUDY
GIULIANI SAID COMEY SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATE AND THAT THE FBI
AGENT "FIRED TODAY AND IN PRISON
NEXT WEEK."
>>LET'S INVESTIGATE THE
INVESTIGATORS.
LET'S STOP AND LET'S TURN AND
GET RID OF ALL THE AGENTS DURING
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
HE SHOULDN'T BE WORKING AT THE
FBI.
HE'S GOT EMOTIONAL PROBLEMS AND
PROBABLY NEEDS VALIUM OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> HE VOWED TO STOP TRUMP FROM
BECOMING PRESIDENT.
STRZOK IS NOW FACING HIS OWN DAY
OF RECKONING.
STRZOK WAS THE LEAD FBI AGENT,
REMEMBER, IN THE CLINTON EMAIL
PROBE, A TOP AGENT IN THE FBI'S
RUSSIA PROBE, AND THE AGENT WHO
INTERVIEWED FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR MIKE FLYNN.
ALL THAT ENDED OF COURSE WHEN
STRZOK'S BOMBASTIC ANTI-TRUMP
TEXTS WERE REVEALED.
HE WAS DEMOTED TO THE FBI'S HR
DEPARTMENT.
WHICH RAISES THE QUESTION, WHY
THE HECK IS HE STILL WORKING AT
THE FBI, ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
THE TEXT MESSAGE REVEALED
YESTERDAY WHERE HE VOWED TO STOP
TRUMP FROM BECOMING PRESIDENT.
JOINING ME NOW, JOHN, ATTORNEY,
AND FORMER ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL, ROBERT DRISCOLL.
ALL RIGHT.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU, BOB,
ON THIS, BECAUSE IT'S
FASCINATING TO ME HOW WHEN YOU
SURVEY THE OTHER NETWORKS OVER
THE LAST 24 HOURS, IT WAS LIKE
ON TO STORMY DANIELS.
THEY SPENT PRECIOUS LITTLE TIME
ON THIS.
THIS IS A BIG NOTHING BURGER.
I'M SO SICK OF THAT WORD, BY THE
WAY.
BUT LET'S REMEMBER WHAT HOROWITZ
DID CONCLUDE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
DEPARTING SO CLEARLY AND
DRAMATICALLY, THE DECISIONS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED THE
PERCEPTIONS OF THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT AS FAIR
ADMINISTRATORS OF JUSTICE.
ROBERT, FAIR ADMINISTRATORS OF
JUSTICE NOW WITH A RUSSIA
COLLUSION PROBE GONE FOR MORE
THAN A YEAR, ABOUT $18 MILLION
IT'S COST, APPARENTLY WITH NO
END IN SIGHT.
>> THE DAMAGE HAS BEEN DONE.
THE REPORT MAKES IT CLEAR THERE
WAS RAMPANT BIAS WITH THE FBI
AND THE DOJ.
ALL THE REPORT SAYS, AND I THINK
PEOPLE TAKE THIS OUT OF CONTEXT.
THE REPORT SAYS THAT HOROWITZ
COULDN'T LINK THE EXAMPLES OF
BIAS TO ANY PARTICULAR
INVESTIGATIVE DECISION.
WHICH OF COURSE HE COULDN'T.
NO ONE WRITES DOWN WHEN THEY'RE
DOING SOMETHING THAT IMPROPER.
BUT HE FOUND BIAS ON EACH PAGE.
INVESTIGATIVE DECISION WAS
DEFENSIBLE.
NOT PROPER, BUT JUST DEFENSIBLE,
HE PASSED ON IT.
SO I THINK IT REALLY IS, TO ME,
SHOCKINGLY BAD, BOTH THE BREADTH
OF THE REPORT AND BIAS AND
CORRUPTION WAS SHOCKING.
>> PETER STRZOK IS STILL
COLLECTING A TAXPAYER-FUNDED
SALARY, WHICH, I MEAN, I CAN'T
BELIEVE HE'S STILL WORKING, AND
OF ALL PLACES, IN HUMAN
RESOURCES.
THAT JUST TAKES THE CAKE.
YOU CAN'T WRITE HOW STUPID THAT
IS.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE BOB GOODLATTE
DOES WANT HIM TO TESTIFY ON
CAPITOL HILL.
HE'S GETTING THAT SUBPOENA.
THE PROCESS TAKES ABOUT TWO
DAYS.
BUT HE WANTS STRZOK ON CAPITOL
HILL AND HE WANTS INFORMATION
AND HE WANTS IT LIKE YESTERDAY.
>> RIGHT.
AND THE QUESTION IS, WHEN YOU
READ THIS SHOCKING REPORT, WHY
HE'S HAD THIS JOB FOR SO LONG,
STRZOK, AND WRAY, WHO THE
PRESIDENT WAS PRAISING IN HIS
TWEETS, WHY THEY HAVEN'T DONE
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS ALREADY.
THERE WAS EVIDENCE OF BIAS.
WE SEE THE SHOCKING INSTANCE OF
THE TEXT THAT HE SENT BACK TO
HIS LOVER ABOUT HOW HE WASN'T
GOING TO LET TRUMP BECOME THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT WAS WITH HELD FROM
CONGRESS.
OBVIOUSLY, IT'S A VERY THOROUGH
REPORT, BUT THE CONCLUSION IS,
WELL, WE DON'T HAVE A SMOKING
GUN, SO WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM ALL ALONG
WITH AN OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL INVESTIGATION.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE POWER TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
AND THAT'S NOT GOING TO CUT IT
HERE WITH THE DAMAGE DONE TO OUR
COUNTRY AND THE DAMAGE BEING
DONE WITH THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
IT REQUIRES STRONGER MEASURES
THAN SIMPLY AN INVESTIGATION
INTO WHAT WENT WRONG.
WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
>> JOHN, THE DAMAGE TO THE FBI,
I THINK, CANNOT BE OVERSTATED
HERE.
WE HAVE MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK
SO HARD IN THE FIELD OFFICES ALL
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY, DAY BY DAY,
NIGHT BY NIGHT, TO KEEP
AMERICANS SAFE AND DO REALLY
GREAT INVESTIGATIVE WORK.
THIS ENDED UP BEING A POLITICAL
RESEARCH OPERATION AGAINST --
ULTIMATELY, AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT WITH THE RUSSIA PROBE,
BUT A CYA SITUATION WITH HILLARY
CLINTON IN THESE EMAILS ALL
ALONG.
IF YOU ACTUALLY READ THIS REPORT
-- I'VE GOTTEN THROUGH MOST OF
IT -- THERE IS A LOT IN THIS
REPORT THAT THE PRESS IS
GLOSSING OVER.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS SOME
HORRIBLE THINGS WERE DONE THAT
SHOULD HAVE NEVER OCCURRED.
WE HAVE TO KEEP IT IN THE
CONTEXT THOUGH.
REMEMBER, THIS IS A GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO KNEW EACH OTHER.
SOME WERE HAND PICKED BY THEIR
FRIENDS TO WORK IN THIS PROJECT,
IF YOU WILL.
MEANWHILE, YOU HAVE 35,000 FBI
EMPLOYEES DOING GOOD THINGS
EVERY DAY.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THEY NEED
TO COME CLEAN.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
WHETHER OR NOT MR. STRZOK SHOULD
BE WORKING AT FBI HEADQUARTERS
IS CERTAINLY A QUESTION WE'RE
ASKING.
>> THE IG DID NOT SAY HE FOUND
NO BIAS AT THE FBI.
HE SAID THAT THERE WAS NO
DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE THAT BIAS
PRODUCED SPECIFIC DECISIONS.
AND WE'VE GOT TO REMEMBER,
THERE'S ANOTHER IG REPORT COMING
DOWN THE PIKE.
THAT COULD END UP BEING LOADED
WITH EVIDENCE OF SUCH BIAS
BECAUSE THAT'S ABOUT LOOKING
INTO THE INFORMANTS THAT WERE
USED IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
MAYBE THE POTENTIAL FISA ABUSES,
THE FBI HANDLING OF THE RUSSIA
PROBE.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO YOU, BOB.
THINKING THE IG -- TRUMP WAS
ANNOYED TODAY.
HE PETERED OUT AT THE END.
I THINK THIS OTHER REPORT COULD
BE REALLY IMPORTANT IN SEEING
WHAT HAPPENS TO PLACED
INDIVIDUALS OR ENCOURAGED
INDIVIDUALS TO TRY TO PENETRATE
THESE LOWER-LEVEL PEOPLE INSIDE
THE CAMPAIGN.
>> WE'LL FIND THE BASIS FOR
THIS RUSSIA INVESTIGATION,
WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS THE
DOSSIER ORIGINALLY OR THE
OPPOSITION RESEARCH GENERATED
INVESTIGATION TOTALLY OR NOT.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, WE'LL BE
ABLE TO LAY IT SIDE BY SIDE WITH
THE IG REPORT THAT JUST CAME
OUT.
IT'LL PROVIDE CONTEXT.
IN THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION, WE
HAVE THE GUY BEING GRANTED
IMMUNITY FOR ESSENTIALLY
NOTHING.
NO PROSECUTION.
I MEAN, ALL THOSE THINGS MAY BE
DEFENSIBLE INDIVIDUALLY IN A
VACUUM, BUT AN INCREDIBLY LIGHT
TOUCH FOR ANYONE WHO'S EVER GONE
THROUGH AN FBI INVESTIGATION.
AND WE'LL GET TO COMPARE THAT
TO, GEE, WHAT DO YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE'S HOUSES ARE BEING
SEARCHED AT 6:00 IN THE MORNING.
AND SO I THINK THIS SECOND
REPORT COULD HAVE -- COULD BE A
BIG DEAL, COULD FILL IN SOME OF
THESE GAPS,
>>GETTING THIS PROFESSOR IN
LONDON.
ALL THIS STUFF THAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO DO.
MY GOODNESS, THEY WERE LEAVING
NO STONE UNTURNED.
TRYING TO GET A RUSSIAN
BILLIONAIRE TO HELP.
THEY'LL DOING EVERYTHING.
MEANWHILE WITH HILLARY, IT'S
LIKE MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T GET THE
WIENER LAPTOP.
MAYBE WE SHOULD WAIT ON THAT.
SO A TOTALLY DIFFERENT APPROACH,
WHICH ALSO COMES THROUGH WHEN
YOU READ THE TOTALITY OF THIS
REPORT.
GIULIANI TODAY TALKED ABOUT THE
QUESTION WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR MONTHS HERE ABOUT
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
TESTIFY.
I WANT YOU ALL TO LISTEN
CAREFULLY TO THIS.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK SHOULD
HAPPEN NOW IN THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION?
>> THEY SHOULD END IT.
THE IG REPORT BASICALLY TELLS
YOU THAT BOTH PRONGS OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION ARE EITHER
CORRUPT OR ANSWERED.
>> AND HE WENT ON TO SAY THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT -- HE
BASICALLY SAID NO INTERVIEW.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULDN'T BE
BOTHERED WITH IT.
ANY THINKING OF YOUR EXCHANGE
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
POSSIBLE PERJURY TRAP?
PRESIDENT TRUMP LIKES TO TALK.
HE LOVES TO GET HIS POINT
ACROSS.
HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG, HE
SAYS.
SO HE'S LIKE, I'M HAPPY TO TALK.
HE WANTS TO TALK.
BUT AS A LAWYER, I'M A LAWYER AS
WELL, HOW DANGEROUS IS IT FOR
HIM TO GO INTO THAT SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE?
>> SO AS FOR THE FIRST PART OF
YOUR QUESTION, DOES IT CHANGE
ANYTHING?
NO.
FROM DAY ONE, I THOUGHT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULDN'T TALK.
THEY'RE THE GUNNERS.
THEY'RE THE GO-GETTERS.
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO WANT TO
MAKE THEIR CASE AND NAME.
NO BIGGER PREY THAN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE SHOULD NOT GO IN THERE
BECAUSE THERE'S NO CONFIDENCE
THAT THE DECK WON'T BE STACKED
AGAINST HIM.
WE'VE SEEN THAT.
BUT IN TERMS OF WITNESSES, A
CEO, A POWERFUL PERSON IS THE
WORST WITNESS.
THEY'RE USED TO GETTING THEIR
WAY.
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM SUCKS UP
TO THEM.
IT'S JUST A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
SCENARIO WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
EVEN SEEMINGLY CASUALLY TO A
PROSECUTOR OR FBI AGENT.
IT WOULD BE A BIG MISTAKE FOR
ANY CEO OR PRESIDENT, BUT
PARTICULARLY FOR THIS PRESIDENT.
NOW WE'VE SEEN THE CORRUPTION
PERVADING THE FBI.
SO ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> GIULIANI'S POINT TODAY WAS,
NOW THAT WE'VE SEEN, WE KNOW
JUST WHAT WAS GOING ON IN THERE
WITH THE DESPERATE EFFORT TO
STOP HIM FROM BECOMING
PRESIDENT, AND SHE GETS TO SIT
IN THERE WHEN THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHETHER THEY SHOULD
SUBPOENA HILLARY, THE COZY
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE PRESS
AND THE FBI AGENTS, THE PRESS
ARE GIVING PERKS TO THE FBI
AGENTS.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE THESE
LEAKS CAME FROM.
TOTALLY OUT OF CONTROL.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO YOU, JOHN,
BECAUSE WE HAVE JOHN WHO
EXCLUSIVELY GAVE US A COMMENT
TONIGHT ABOUT WHAT THIS IG
REPORT ACTUALLY SAYS.
THE CLEAR EVIDENCE OF HIS USURP
OF POWER, VIOLATION OF OATH OF
OFFICE, AND MATERIAL FALSE
STATEMENTS OF THE PUBLIC AND
CONGRESS, ALL TO CONCEAL HIS OWN
CONDUCT.
THE FINDING OF NO BIAS WAS
LUDICROUS.
THE OIG'S FINDINGS SUPPORT THE
DECISION TO FIRE COMEY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE WAS FIRED BECAUSE OF THE
THINGS HE HAD DONE AND THE
PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT TO TAKE
THOSE ACTIONS.
I ALSO THINK A LOT OF THINGS
HAVE BEEN MADE OUT OF THE FACT
THAT THE PRESIDENT FIRED THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
IT'S NOT UNPRECEDENTED.
WE SAW IT WITH WILLIAM SESSIONS.
BUT THIS IS CLEARLY BASED ON THE
REPORT WE'RE SEEING, GIVES GOOD
CAUSE AND JUSTIFICATION TO THE
ACTIONS THE PRESIDENT TOOK.
>> THERE WAS ALSO THE SHOCKING
DEVELOPMENT TODAY.
A FEDERAL JUDGE APPOINTED BY
OBAMA ACTUALLY JAILED PAUL AFTER
MUELLER CLAIMED HE TRIED TO
TAMPER WITH WITNESSES.
GIULIANI RESPONDED BY FLOATING
THE IDEA OF PRESIDENTIAL PARDONS
IN THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
ROBERT, THIS LED JEFFREY TO SAY
THE FOLLOWING ABOUT GIULIANI.
WATCH.
>> IT IS SO CORRUPT AND
UNETHICAL WHAT GIULIANI SAID.
I MEAN, WE ARE IN AN AREA HERE
THAT IS LITERALLY
UNPRECEDENTEDED BECAUSE NOT THAT
MANY PEOPLE IN AMERICAN LIFE
HAVE THE POWER TO GIVE A PARDON.
WE ARE SO FAR OUT OF NORMAL
ETHICAL BEHAVIOR, THAT IT'S JUST
WORTH PRESERVING OUR SENSE OF
OUTRAGE ABOUT IT BECAUSE SO MUCH
OF THIS STUFF HAPPENS EVERY DAY.
BUT IT REALLY IS APPALLING.
>> A SENSE OF OUTRAGE.
JEFFREY AND THAT OUTRAGE.
ROBERT, NEVERTHELESS, THE
THROWING OUT THE PARDON THING.
I PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE DONE
THAT IF I WERE RUDY TODAY.
>> WELL, AND THE OTHER REASON
TOO IS JUST STRATEGICALLY AS A
DEFENSE LAWYER, I WOULDN'T WANT
HIM PARDONED BEFORE THE CASE IS
OVER.
AND SO IF HE IS PARDONED, HE NO
LONGER FACING CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
HE COULD CONCEIVABLY BE FORCED
TO TESTIFY.
AND MORE OVER, THERE'S JUST NO
REASON TO HANDLE IT NOW.
YOU JUST WAIT AND SEE WHERE THE
CHIPS FALL.
AND IF SOME POINT LATER THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO PARDON, HE
CAN.
AS FAR AS BEING UNPRECEDENTED,
GEORGE BUSH SR. PARDONED THE DAY
BEFORE THE TRIAL.
IT'S BEEN DONE.
THERE'S NO QUESTION IT'S THE
INHERENT POWER THE PRESIDENT
HAS.
THERE'S NO REAL CHECK ON IT.
I JUST CAN'T GET THAT OUTRAGE
THOUGH.
THE ANSWER TO IT IS A POLITICAL
ANSWER, WHICH IS IT WAS DONE
PUBLICLY AND THE PRESIDENT CAN
SUFFER BLOWBACKS IF HE DOES IT.
>> AND WE HAD A MYRIAD OF
INSTANCES WHERE THE OBAMA
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT -- WE HAD
ERIC HOLDER HELD IN CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS OVER THE DOCUMENTS, I
THINK IT WAS FAST AND FURIOUS.
THERE'S NO MORAL OUTRAGE.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> YEAH.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO GIVE HIM THE
SMELLING SALT, THE SELECTIVE
OUTRAMBLING, THE HYPOCRISY IS
LAUGHABLE.
THEY SHOULD BE CONCERNED AS
AMERICANS ABOUT THE CORRUPTION
OF THE FBI AND OTHER AGENCIES OF
THE GOVERNMENT AND NOT ABOUT
THIS ONE INSTANCE.
I OUTRAGED THAT A JUDGE IS
APPEARING TO USE AN
INCARCERATION AS A PENALTY AS A
PUNISHMENT PRIOR TO A TRIAL.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE USED IN
PREVENTIVE ATTENTION WHERE IT
DEALS WITH FLIGHT RISKS AND
OTHER ISSUES.
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD BE
OUTRAGED ABOUT.
>> SHE WAS REALLY LECTURING
TODAY SAYING BASICALLY YOU'RE
NOT IN JUNIOR HIGH.